I wanted to play this song before you uh
that is um a Willie Nelson tune because
we were talking Funny How Time Slips
Away did you do this in front of them
um yes I did this on his 90th birthday
oh this is the one
well hello there
my it's been a long long time
well how am I doing
well I guess I'm doing fine
well it's been so long but it seems like
it was
only yesterday
ain't it funny
how time
Slips Away
[Music]
well how's your new love
I hope is doing fine
[Music]
and I heard you told him
you'd love them till the end of time
now that's the same thing you told me
seems like
just the other day
ain't it funny
how time
Slips Away
[Music]
Louisiana
thank you
[Music]
well I got to go now
and I guess I see you around
[Music]
I don't know
don't know when I'll be back in town
but remember
what I'll tell you
you cause in time you're gonna pay
it's surprising
time
Slips Away
[Music]
yeah remember
what I tell you
cause in time you're gonna pay
[Music]
surprising
no time
Slips Away
[Music]
just beautiful man